- [Instructor] In previous videos,
we talk about the emergence
of the Maurya Empire,
around 322 BCE,
shortly after the invasion
of Alexander the Great,
as the first truly great Indian empire
that unifies most of
the Indian subcontinent.
That empire eventually falls,
and the next significant empire to emerge,
especially if we talk about
influence on India and the world,
is the Gupta Empire, which
emerges over 500 years later.
Let's zoom in on our timeline
to get a deeper appreciation
of the Gupta Empire.
It's believed that its
start was with Sri Gupta,
he started the Gupta Dynasty around 240,
and it's disputed where they emerged,
it might have been in that
region or in that region.
There's different accounts of where
the Gupta Dynasty initially emerged,
but even in the early 300's,
they really had a control
of a few small kingdoms.
It wasn't until the
reign of Chandragupta I
that it becomes a significant dynasty.
We need to be careful.
Don't confuse this
Chandragupta, the First,
with Chandragupta Maurya, who
founded the Maurya Dynasty
over 600 years before the
time we're talking about.
Chandragupta I, it's interesting because
he is really able to gain power,
not initially through conquest,
but through a marriage.
He has a marriage with
the princess Kumaradevi,
and as a dowry, he's given control over
much of this region of northeast India.
This region of Magadha or Magadha,
I am always having
trouble pronouncing that,
so my apologies,
including the famous city of Pataliputra,
which even at the time
of the Maurya Empire
and before the Maurya Empire,
this was a famous seat of power.
But once he's in control of this region,
then he and his successors are able
to have increased conquests over India.
You see in this light blue color
what his son Samudragupta was able to do,
and then one of Samudragupta's sons,
Chandragupta II, is able
to conquer even more.
But what makes the
Gupta Empire distinctive
isn't just that they
were able to unify much,
or conquer much, of India again.
What really makes them distinctive
is because of that unification,
and especially the
wealth that began to flow
into the capitol,
they were able to be sponsors
of significant culture,
and science, and the arts.
That's why historians
view the Gupta Empire
as the golden age of India.
Just to get an appreciation for this,
the Gupta Empire was during
the time of Kalidasa,
and he is considered to be
the greatest writer ever
in the Sanskrit language.
He is the William Shakespeare of Sanskrit.
Beyond literature and writing,
you have significant
contributions to science,
most notably, Aryabhata.
He's known for a very
accurate approximation of pi,
but even more important, a recognition
that was an approximation,
and that he potentially recognized
the irrationality of pi,
one of the first to do so.
The word sin, the trig function,
is derived from Aryabhata's
word for that function,
so he established some of the
early ideas of trigonometry.
He did work in summation,
he did significant astronomical work,
recognizing the rotation of the Earth
versus the rotation of the heavens.
He had an early concept of gravity.
Even some of these
notions of the place value system,
and zero, and decimal notation,
many of our modern notions of it
are traced back to Aryabhata.
In other videos on the Islamic golden age,
when we talk about
folks like al-Khwarizmi,
a lot of his work was based on
what he learned from Aryabhata.
Beyond the sciences, and once again,
this is just a sample of all that happened
during this period,
you have the significant
Hindu epics, the Mahabharata,
the Ramayana, the Periyas, get
written down and formalized.
You can say they were canonized.
The game of chess,
or the early version of the game of chess,
was invented, called chaturanga,
and they had horsemen,
which were the knights,
they had infantry, which were the pawns,
they had elephants, which
eventually turned into bishops,
but as it migrated into
Persia, the Muslim world,
and then into Europe, it became
our modern game of chess.
Famously, there is this iron pillar,
that is now in New Delhi,
that is traced back to the
time of the Gupta Empire,
and is believed to the
reign of Chandragupta II.
What's amazing about this,
this is a pillar that's over 20 feet high,
made out of raw iron, and
over 1500, 1600 years,
it hasn't corroded.
It has inscriptions on
it that help historians
point to the Gupta Empire.
This is some of the coinage
of the Gupta Empire.
So the big takeaway here is,
this was India's golden age,
the classical period of India.
A lot of modern Hinduism
and Indian culture
can be traced back to this time period.
But it isn't just its influence on India.
In other videos, we talk
about the Islamic golden age,
and much of that golden age,
which emerges two, three,
400 years after the time,
after the Gupta Empire falls,
much of that work in
based on the discoveries
and the work that is collected
during the time of the Guptas,
and then that becomes
a bridge, eventually,
to the European Renaissance.
Now, like all empires,
the Gupta Empire does eventually fall,
in the mid-sixth century,
it's believed around 540, 550,
and one of the main causes,
there is invasions from
people called the Hunas,
who historians believe
are either the Huns,
or a group that are closely
related to the Huns.
It's considered to be one of the causes
of the eventual decline
of the Gupta Dynasty.